we have this big story that's breaking
today about crime a crime that must be
addressed breaking Jamal Bowman to plead
guilty to pulling firearm in capital in
exchange for charges dropped $11,000
fine in sweetheart deal we got him there
he is ladies and gentlemen inist the
insurrectionist has been apprehending I
mean this was this was 911 all over
again you know when when he when oh yeah
it was it was worse it was almost as bad
as January 6 they're not going to give
you that sweetheart deal if you go you
mean January 6 was almost as bad as
this you know because nobody pulled a a
fire alarm on January 6
to that's horrific but they were saying
that September 11th was not as bad as
January 6 remember that oh oh there's
still people there's still people that
say that yeah their argument is they
were subverting democracy there's people
that believe by staying within the
Velvet ropes well right this is it Jamal
Bowman says I am responsible for
activating a fire alarm I will be paying
the f
issued yeah okay is it his first offense
cuz I think that's fair I do is it
absolutely first offense I don't know
Tim soft on crime I don't know about
that let's face it what he did is is
literally an offense against democracy
it actually is he was trying to stall he
was trying to prevent a vote from taking
place in Congress and it's been treated
like a misdemeanor false
alarm you'd think he was just
trespassing in the capital that would be
I remember I was um I would uh after
January 6 I would send people pictures
of like the C what happened with
Kavanagh with people inside and people
would be like oh that didn't happen no
no I'd say like yes like when this
happened they're like yes look how awful
that is I'm like yes look how awful that
is yeah you remember when Amy Schumer
like occupied the Supreme Court and got
arrested remember when Jane Fonda every
Friday decided to get arrested outside
the capital for climate change and she
would like fly her jeted from La so she
could sit on the steps of Congress and
get arrested said what a fool these
people are but they don't care about the
contradictions I mean that's the thing
about Democrats is they just don't seem
to be either aware of the contradictions
or they just don't care they're aware no
I used to fall into that camp like like
if you look at like I I always reference
the the Instagram account defiant El's
which always posts the people who
contradict themselves often times just
like a day later I used to be like look
maybe these people are just dumb they're
not dumb they're evil right they do not
care because look what they said first
reached a certain C amount of people
when they post that second thing that
contradicts what they said completely
that reaches a whole another demographic
of people maybe 10 of maybe 10 20% of
those people see the contradiction but
they're so ideologically captured
anyways it doesn't matter maybe you
change maybe 5% of those people see it
and say wow I I don't know if I fall in
line with that uh that seems like a
contradiction but they don't care yeah
they're not they're not worried about it
it's like what is it it's like hierarchy
not uh not hypocrisy it doesn't matter
to them yeah if hierarchy hierarchy
hypocrisy what does that mean it means
that the people who are committing these
hypocrisies they are sort of blatantly
doing it to show you that they're above
it that it doesn't matter that they're
being critical that truth is Tru is
malleable that reality is as they see it
not how you see it there doesn't need to
I mean and it's like there doesn't need
to be a value system if you just you
know it's just this constant shifting
ideological sand and it doesn't matter
where you stand it doesn't you can't
build anything on it so they just come
up with what's that the gold post are
moving anyways yeah the gold post are
moving anyway so they it's like oh I
scored well the gold posts are over
there not anymore now they're here I've
even heard more insane rationalizations
that say look if they were to make those
contradictions in their personal life
with friends and family that would be
bad but in the service of political
agenda it's okay because it's in service
to maintaining power and the only thing
that matters is maintaining power and
that's and if that's not the definition
of evil I don't know what that's evil
well there's a lot of there's a lot of
things that I think we could Define as
evil but for sure that's one of them
yeah yeah that in the evil of the crowds
who get together and commit Mass
violence just because they think it's
fun or yeah just because they're they're
spurred on remember I remember when I
was a kid and there would be always um
there were always these stories about
people being trampled in India and it
would be like or in Saudi Arabia or like
at Mecca or something and it would
always be just like you know somebody
sneezed and the crowd went wild and 200
people got trampled to death I always
wondered how does this happen how do you
just start bugging out like that and
think about that now in cities like New
York City where there's so many people
congregated in such small space like
that's just to me what it is like we've
built these cities up so high now that
it's like yes uh a a large majority of
those people may be able to with
withstand the idea of falling victim to
crowd mentality right but you're putting
yourself at risk every day by being
around it well the thing about New York
and crowd mentality is there's ways that
you behave within the crowd of New York
City that you would never behave beh
somewhere else like um you know where I
live now people say hi to each other and
in New York if you said hi to everybody
you passed you'd never get where you
were going you know you never make eye
contact with anybody which is still
something that I do it's like I'm never
going to make eye contact with strangers
because what if they're crazy and then
I'm in their line of sight and the next
thing you know you know you're a target
of the crazy person just because you
looked at them or they're trying to fund
raise for a nonprofit and as soon as you
lock they got you that's terrible look
and and not just like if you come from a
small town and you go to New York City
they and you do greet someone they don't
say hello they say who's this right like
why are you talking to me go away you
have to get used to the different
different social setting different one
of the things that I always found so
interesting about New York is how
people's private lives unfold in public
you know you'll see somebody just in
tears on the subway people just walk by
and like no and you know and like there
have been times when I've been literally
like sobbing on the subway and an old
woman will hand me a tissue and be like
like are you okay so we we have some
breaking updates CNN is now reporting 16
people have died in Leon main with 50 to
60 injuries wow they're investigating
multiple active shooter events a suspect
remains at large we are encouraging all
businesses to lock down or close while
we investigate main State Police also
said they responding to an active
shooter situation on Facebook please
lock your doors so the concern is it
looks like it's multiple uh uh areas
this could be one person and who's moved
to different areas but some people are
concerned it's more than one person uh
according like I've read in the chat at
least I know the report said there was
Middle Eastern men uh lot of the chat I
don't know yeah I don't I no there's a
there's a photo that was released that
could be a person of Middle Eastern
descent um I encourage people to just to
look for these official news sources and
then wait till make a determination for
yourself don't make assumptions about
what you think a person looks like look
at the actual photo but I'm concerned
that there are there are fake accounts
spreading this specifically to Fan the
Flames of of of a conflict so that could
be it right so watch out for that yep
Hannah Nightingale who's working on this
story right now at post millennial is
from Maine and she's saying well that's
she's normally not on this late but if
it's a main thing she you know she'll
come check it out but I was just there
yeah she she said that there's never
been a mass shooting like this in Maine
before there's not a lot of people yeah
it's like the biggest city in Maine is
like 40,000 people or something it's
little it's a little I mean it's a big
state with not that many people in it as
you just said y That's the whole thing
well I don't know man if you're in main
if yeah right but if if you know if
Maine isn't
safe this is what the gun why we're in
West Virginia right West Virginia like
has its issues too but at least in West
Virginia you can have guns right can you
have guns the Maine pass a reckless
permitless carry law says gords I'm just
reading it that's what gford says yeah
that's why I pointed out initially that
I'm I'm reading this from the internet
uh permitless carry law 2015 that allows
residents to carry concealed without a
permitter background check 2A so um and
in in 2021 made had the 14th lowest gun
death rate wow interesting so that's
actually pretty interesting what's
gord's I don't even know what that is
Gabby gords oh that's Gabby gford oh
right because she was shot in the head
so you know she's worried about gun loss
makes sense once you're shot in the head
but well she's not I think she's evil
because she has armed security guards
and gets government protection and then
tries to for everyone else right so she
has guns they're just being held by
other people what she's actually saying
is only we may have cake right hierarchy
not hypocrisy do the do the people who
protect California politicians have to
adhere to California gun laws as far as
like magazine size usually they uh this
is how it works right so like in
Venezuela during the protests if you're
if you're on the side of the government
you're getting a full belly every night
and that's why they do it everyone else
is starving and they tell you you want
to be starving with them and protesting
go ahead and do do it you want a full
belly you take the gun you stop them
from protesting that when when you like
these people who who uh protect
politicians have restrictions often they
have to when like they they're allowed
to carry their gun only while they're on
duty but 10 round mags they're allowed
to have a gun at their house or
something like that in a lot of states
that make it very difficult to do yeah
oh and they probably get special
benefits like that for sure yeah yeah
Illinois which was always super
restrictive uh but if you're if you're
protecting the politicians you're good
then you're all right to do it yeah if
you're if you're cop you're good if
you're part of the machine and
protecting the people in power you're
good everyone else it's all about power
it's always all about just maintaining
power course you know well yeah for
whatever reason for whatever reason I
mean I just don't understand want that
kind of it's amazing how it just always
kind of plots out that way and but not
not everybody has this uh uh this this
mental state ambition drift no that's
not absolutely not it like the I have
plenty of ambition but I'm not
interested in maintaining power yeah I
mean in ambition doesn't mean killing
people for personal gain or causing Mass
suffering like no no that's I mean yeah
what what what what some there are
people out there that are just they
Revel in causing suffering of others
yeah totally mhm hence why there's
probably a mass shooting right now
that's another evil thing wanting to
cause harm wanting to hurt people like
uh like pulling a fire alarm to stop
Congress right that's horrifying evil
how does he live with
himself I think he does just fine so
there's gonna they're gonna drop the
charges I think he should go to jail I
think he should definitely go he should
get community community service enough
to serve it with Jenna Ellis together
that's what they should do thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net